[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى من القدس نتابع هذه
الصور المباشره عشيه ما يسمى بمسيره
الاعلام المرتقب تنظيمها غدا الخميس وسط
تاهب وتخوف من اشتعال الاوضاع في القدس
وهذه الصور من واشنطن تحديدا البيت الابيض
بعد تصريحات للرئيس بايدن اكد فيها ثقته
بالتوصل الى اتفاق مع خصومه الجمهوريين
على رفع سقف الدين العام بشكل يتيح
للولايات المتحده تفادي التخلف عن سداد
ديونها
ومن مانشستر تريدون هذه الصور مانشستر
التي تستضيف مباراه اياب نصف النهائي
لدوري ابطال اوروبا بين مانشستر سيتي
وريال مدريد الشوط الاول انتهى بتقدم
السيتي بهدفين نظيفين وفي مواضيع الحصاد
لهذه الليله
مع استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان البرهان
يظهر في الميدان لاول مره منذ اندلاع
المعارك الجيش يؤكد استعاده السيطره على
مواقع فقدها في العاصمه الدعم السريع يقول
ان قواته تصدت لهجوم على مواقعها في منطقه
شمال بحري والامم المتحده تشير الى ان نصف
سكان السودان بحاجه لمساعدات انسانيه
جبهه باخمو تتصدر المشهد في الحرب
باوكرانيا كيف تقول انها تواصل تحقيق
التقدم في الضواحي الشماليه والجنوبيه
للمدينه والجيش الروسي يؤكد ان قواته
تواصل التقدم في الاحياء الغربيه وقبل يوم
من انتهاء العمل به الاعلان عن تمديد
اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه لشهرين
اضافيين
عشيه مسيره الاعلام بمستوطنين متطرفين في
القدس المحتله الشرطه الاسرائيليه تحشد
3000 من افرادها لتامين المسيره الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه تقول الى الاصرار على تنظيمها
سيؤدي الى تفجير الاوضاع وحماس تدعو الى
التصدي للمسيره والاشتباك مع الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
الازمه الباكستانيه ونظر تصعيد جديد رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان يقول اذا شرطه
تحاصر منزله وان اعتقاله بات وشيكا محكمه
اسلام اباد العليا تجدد امر منع اعتقاله
وحزب انصاف المؤيد له يطالب بالافراج عن
الاف المعتقلين من انصاره على خلفيه
الاضطرابات الاخيره بينهم قاده من الحزب
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا حاله الترقب والتوتر التي
تعيشها القدس على وقع ما تسمى مسيره
الاعلام التي تنظمها جماعات يمنيه متطرفه
غدا الخميس في ذكرى احتلال القدس الشرقيه
وفق التقويم العبري لاستطاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم ما هي التداعيات المحتمله
لمسيره المستوطنين المتطرفين في القدس
المحتله
20% توقعوا تفجير الاوضاع في القدس بينما
قال 30% انهم انها ستؤدي لمزيد من تصعيد
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اما 50% فراوا انها
ستدفع نحو واجهات فلسطينيه اسرائيليه
واسعه النطاق
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مرشحان رئاسه التركيه يكثفان حملتيهما
لحسم جوله الاعاده اردوغان يعلن عزمه
زياره متضرري زلزال وكليجدار اوغلو يغازل
اصوات القوميه
[موسيقى]
قال اعلام مجلس السياده السوداني ان
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه عبد الفتاح
البرهان قام بجوله في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش وسط العاصمه الخرطوم واكد مصدر
عسكري في الجيش للجزيره ان قوات الجيش
استعادت السيطره على مواقع عسكريه فقدتها
امس في العاصمه من جهه ثانيه اعلنت الامم
المتحده انها بحاجه الى مليارين
و560 مليون دولار
وسط جنوده يظهر البرهان يقول مجلس السياده
السوداني ان رئيسه قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان تجول في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش يحمل البرهان سلاحه في اول ظهور
ميداني له منذ اندلاع الازمه قبل شهر
وايام وفق مقاطع الفيديو فان البرهان
ظهر في مركز القوات البريه بالعاصمه هنا
تجري العمليات العسكريه الرئيسيه لكلا
الطرفين غير بعيد يعلن الجيش السوداني
احباظ هجمات لما سماها ميليشيا الدعم
السريع من ثلاثه اتجاهات مختلفه
تهدف هذه الهجمات وفق الجيش الى زعزعه
الاستقرار في القاعده الجويه العسكريه
بمنطقه وادي سيدنا في ام درمان بالاضافه
الى استهداف الدعم السريع لقياده القطاع
الاوسط للقوات الجويه وفرع الرياضه
العسكريه وسط الخرطوم يقول الجيش انه
استعاد السيطره على هذه المناطق بعد
انسحابه منها لساعات يوم امس
في المقابل تقول قوات الدعم السريع انما
وصفتها بقوه الانقلابيين وفولو النظام
البائد حاولت مباغته ارتكازات قواتها في
منطقه شمال الخرطوم بحري بثت قوات الدعم
مقطع فيديو قالت انه يظهر سيطرتها على
قياده قوات الدفاع الجوي في الخرطوم
الليله الماضيه عقب معارك مع الجيش
السوداني ذلك المكان الذي اكد الجيش
استعاده السيطره عليه بعد الانسحاب لساعات
سياسيا لا تزال جده السعوديه مسرح محادثات
لم توقف اطلاق النار على الارض السودانيه
يقول مصدر دبلوماسي سوداني مطلع للجزيره
ان المفاوضات بواسطه امريكيه سعوديه لا
تزال متواصله بشكل غير رسمي انسانيا اعلنت
الامم المتحده انها بحاجه الى مليارين
وخمسمائه وستين مليون دولار في اطار خطتها
للاستجابه الانسانيه في السودان يشير
مسؤول الامم المتحده الى ان 220 الف شخص
اصبحوا لاجئين في مصر وتشاد وجنوب السودان
جراء الاقتتال المستمر في السودان وهو
يدخل شهره
ينضم الينا من باريس محمد تورشين الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك سيد
محمد
من وراء الظهور العلني للبرهان بين عناصر
وافراد القوات المسلحه اليوم
المشاهدين الكرام هي بلاشك ذات الرسائل
ودلالات اولها محاوله التاكيد بان البرهان
هو الذي يدير هذه المعارك وهو على قيد
الحياه فضلا عن ذلك تسهم بشكل كبير جدا في
رفع الروح المعنويه للجنود والمقاتلين لا
زيما بان هذه المعارك مستمره لقرابه الشهر
والان في شهرها الثاني او هنالك ايضا
محاولات من قبل قوات الدعم السريعين لا
تسيطر على بعض المناطق والمكاتب الاداريه
للقوات المسلحه كفرع الرياضه العسكريه او
مكاتب اداره القوات الجويه وما الى ذلك
فانا في تقدير الغرض منها ارسال الرسائل
بانه هو الذي يسيطر هو الذي يدير هذه
المعارك باعتبار ان الاتهامات ظلت تطال
القيادات الجيش بان هنالك عناصر من فلور
النظام الباقي التي تسيطر على المؤسسه
العسكريه وهي التي تدير هذه المعارك وهذه
الصور هذه المقاطع يرسل رساله وانه حاضر
وهو في ميدان القطار ايضا يحمل قناصه
يقاتل في صفوف جنوده طيب كلا الطرفين
يدعيان انهما يحرزان تقدما في الميدان كيف
يمكن تقييم في هذه المرحله ما يحدث
ميدانيا كما ذكرت بعد ان يعني دخلت
المواجهات الشهر الثاني
الوحده الاولى كله طرف يزعه خلال مقاطع
الصور او البيانات توثيق وتاكيد حالته لكن
الناظر للمقاطع النادره ما نجد ان القوات
المسلحه والجيش السوداني يتعمد تصوير بعض
المناطق التي دخلها بصوره منظمه في اداره
الترجيح المعنى وما الى ذلك معظم هذه
المقاطع المقاطع فرديه لكن في الاتجاه
الاخر بنار السريع فكان يعتمد على هذا
السلاح بشكل منتظم جدا في اعتبار انه في
كل مرحله يتم توثيق بالمناطق التي يسيطرون
عليها كذلك بعض الاثر الذين
يسرونهم اثناء المعارك وكذلك بعض الذين
يتحدثون مع انهم ينحذروهم بمعنى ان الدعم
السريع ربما هو في الجانب الاعلامي استعد
لهذه المعركه منذ فتره طويله وتدرب عدد
كبير جدا من العناصر لان كل شخص لديه
خلفيه اعلاميه تمام بان المقاطع التي يتم
نشرح في مواقع الدعم السريع هي مقاطع تشبه
بالاعترافيه يتم انتاجها بشكل جيد فانا في
تقديري الحرب الان في اطار عدم قدرته
وسائل الاعلام المحايده وكذلك وكاله
الانباء في انها تتحرك بحريه تامه لنقل
الرصد الصوره بشكل جيد في تقدير ستظل هذه
الصور التي ترفق من الجيش وكذلك الدعم
السري والبيانات هي مصدرها الخبر بالرغم
ان محمد في ظل كل هذا المشهد
ما انعكاس كل ذلك على ما يجري في جده
المحادثات الحاصله في جده وهل مازال يؤمل
بان تخرج بشيء
انا في تقدير كل المعارك التي تدور منذ
الامس واليوم هي هدفها تعزيز المواقف
التفاوض في جده باعتبار ان الملاحظ في في
طوال الفتره الماضيه كانت قوات الدعم
السريع تسيطر على القصر الجمهوري وكذلك
بعض المناطق المهمه ولا تتحرك كثيرا نحو
الاستيلاء على على مناطق عسكريه اخرى او
منشات حيث كانت فقط
متواجده وسط الاحياء وكذلك وسط المدينه من
الطيران الحربي لكن عندما بدات الجوله
الثانيه من المباحثات في جده راينا ان هذا
هذه القوات بدات تتحرك نحو بعض المنشات
كلها الحيويه والعسكريه الغرض من ذلك هو
دعم وتعزيز الموقف والتفاوض ومعلومه تماما
ان كل العمليات وكذلك الموقف العملياتي له
انعكاس مباشر على مسار التقاعد فبالتالي
انا في تقدير هذا الامر عدم قدره غير طرف
انه يحسم هذه المعركه بشكل على مدار
الفتره الماضيه هو سينعكس سربا على مجريات
المباحثات في جده ما لم يكون هنالك
الانتصار او حسني عسكري يا واضح المعالم
المسلحه انا في تقدير باي حال من الاحوال
لن تتقدم مباحث جدا نحو الامر شكرا جزيلا
لك من باريس محمد تورشن الكاتب والباحث
السياسي السوداني
[موسيقى]
الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وتحديدا جبهه
باخموت المواجهات الحاصله على جبهه تعد
اطول حاله اشتباك متواصله بين القوات
الروسيه ومسلحي مجموعه فاجنر من جهه
والقوات الاوكرانيه من جهه اخرى لم تحسم
بشكل كامل لكن اخبارها الجديده عكست
تغييرا في موازين السيطره ولو بشكل بطيء
نتعرف على ابرز وشراء المشهد المستجده في
ضخمه
بلده بخموت في منطقه شرقيه اوكرانيا والتي
كانت ذات يوم موطنا لاكثر من 70 الف شخص
هي اسخن جبهه للقتال منذ عده اشهر بين
القوات الاوكرانيه والقوه الروسيه ومعها
ميلي احدث فصولها بعد اشهر من تقدم
والسيطره شبه كليه روسيه معلنه اعلان
الجيش الاوكراني تمكنه ولاول مره من
استعاده اراد في شمال المدينه وجنوبها ومن
كسر الطوق شبه المحكم عليها نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني قالت ان قوتي بلادها
حررت نحو 20 كيلومترا مربعا شمالا وجنوب
ضواحي بخموت وتظهر باللون الازرق ودفعت
القوات الروسيه نحو الشمال والجنوب الغربي
لعده كيلومترات
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تحدثت بدورها عن
نجاح تكتيكيا اوكراني في الايام الاربعه
الاخيره واشارت الى ان الجيش الاوكراني
يعمل حاليا على كبح الهجوم الروسي عند خط
قناه
وتحويل الممر المائي الى جزء من شريط
دفاعي عميق حول مدينه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان وحداتها الهجوميه
تواصل تقدمها في الاحياء الغربيه من بخموت
وان قوات الانزال المحموله جوا سيطرت على
مواقع دفاعيه جيده خلال هجوم لها واشار
مالك مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه
في تسجيل صوتي الى تقدم وحداته 200 متر
واحتلالها نحو 113 الف متر مربع لكن قائد
القوات البريه الاوكرانيه اولكسندر سيرسكي
وصف بلده بخموت المحاصره بانها مصيده
فئران للقوات الروسيه من خلال الدفاع
الناشط لقواته وشنها هجمات مضاده ويشير
محللون عسكريون الى ان ما يحدث في بخموت
محاوله اوكرانيه لتثبيت القوات الروسيه في
المدينه واجبارها على البقاء في نقطه
معينه بينما تختار القوات الاوكرانيه
العديد من المناطق لمهاجمتها وتشكل نتائج
الوضع على جبهه بخموت اهميه لكل الطرفين
هبسطت السيطره الروسيه عليها تهديد لمدن
رئيسيه اخرى مجاوره ابرزها سلوفيانسك
واكراماتورسك مركز العمليه الاوكرانيه
وخسارتها تدريجيا واستعاده الاوكرانيين
لها او لاجزاء منها انتكاسه عسكريه
وسياسيه لروسيا ولمجموعه فاجنر ودعم معنوي
لكييف وهي تخوض ما تسميه هجوما مضاده
لاستعاده اراضيها
حول هذا الموضوع معنا هنا في الاستوديو
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك عميد الياس حنا كيف
يمكن تقييم هذا التقدم الذي تتحدث
اوكرانيا عن احرازه في باخمت
اولا مخبوط هي ليست ذات قيمه استراتيجيه
اليوم اصبحت ذات قيمه سياسيه خسارتها
مشكله
وعدم ربحها هي مشكله لبريكوجين وحتى
للرئيس بوتين اليوم
التقدم يعني هناك عده اوضاع استنزاف فاجنر
عدم مساهمه الجيش الروسي الاساسي في الحرب
بشكل بشكل معين من هنا التقدم يعني حسب
الجيش الاوكراني وجدوا ثغره الجيش
الاوكراني جاهز مع تعزيزات فحدث الخرق
اثنين كيلو متر او ثلاثه كيلو متر مربع
فاتت قوات روسيه من زفاف من الشمال
وباتجاه هذه المنطقه هذا الامر يدل ان
هناك تدفورتات يعني فعل ورد الفعل وقد
تكون هناك يعني او هذه المنطقه هي ليست من
ضمن الهجوم الكبير والذي يعد له ولكن قد
تكون احدى الجبهات لانه اليوم عندما نقول
اهاجم اليوم ساهاجم في مكان ما وهذا امر
يندرج في موضوع الخداع كما قالوا في مرحله
من المراحل سننهاجم في خرسون فاتت في
خركاب ولكن الجيش الروسي اليوم هو اكثر
استعدادا وما نشهده اليوم من قصف خاصه على
المدينه وخاصه في العمق وفي خلفيه جيش
الاوكراني هذا امر يدل ان الجيش الروسي
يريد امرين مهمين ضرب المنظومه الدفاعيه
المتمثله وغيرها وبالتالي خفض مستوى
الجهوزيه واللوجستيه للجيش الاوكراني
لمنعه من القيام بالهجوم كما يريد هل هل
ينجح في هذه الاهداف راينا في الايام
الماضيه تكثيفا للضربات الروسيه على المدن
سواء في الجنوب وفي كييف ايضا تكثيف كبير
لهذا الاستهداف هل ينجح في هذه الاهداف
لا يمكن قياس النجاح اليوم لانه قبل خرسون
قال البعض كيف سيتصرف الجيش الاوكراني
اليوم لا يمكن قياس هذا النجاح لانه القصف
لا ينهي حرب الاحتلال والعسكر على الارض
هو الذي يهني الحرب اليوم تسعه الويه
اوكرانيه مع 1500 مدرعه 230 دبابه اصبحت
جاهزه يبقى اليوم موضوع الطقس هو العامل
الاساسي
اشكرك جزيل الشكر العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان انه
تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر
موانئ البحر الاسود لمده شهرين اضافيين
تاتي تصريحات اردوغان قبيل يوم واحد من
انتهاء مده الاتفاق غدا الخميس
وقد اعرب الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو بوتيريش عن ترحيبه بتمديد اتفاق
الحبوب وعن امله في التوصل الى اتفاق اشمل
اضافش ان بعض القضايا العالقه ما زالت
موجوده لكن ممثلي روسيا واوكرانيا وتركيا
والامم المتحده سيواصلون مناقشتها واشار
الى انه تم تصدير اكثر من 30 مليون طن من
الغذاء في اطار مبادره البحر الاسود وهما
يكفي لاطعام 150 مليون شخص لمده عام واحد
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نسال ضيف الحصاد
عن اهميه تمديد اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه وفرص اقرار اتفاق اكثر استدابه
[موسيقى]
تنظم سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ما تسمى
مسيره الاعلام او رقصه الاعلام التي بدات
للمره الاولى عام
1968 للاحتفال باحتلال شطري مدينه القدس
وفق التقويم اليهودي فالعرض التالي نتعرف
على مسيره الاعلام وما تثيره من ازمات
نظمت المسيره للمره الاولى عام
1968 على يد الحاخام يهودا حساني من
المدرسه الدينيه المعروفه باسم مركازهاراف
وتحولت الى تقليد سنوي تنظم فيما تسميه
السلطات الاحتلال يوم القدس والذي تحيي
فيه ذكر احتلال الشطر الشرقي من المدينه
وفق التقويم العبري عام 67
يمول المسيره جمعيه عام كبيبه الدينيه
الاستيطانيه وبلديه القدس ووزاره التربيه
والتعليم الاسرائيليه وشركه تطوير واعاده
تاهيل الحي اليهودي وفي يوم المسيره تجبر
قوات الاحتلال الفلسطينيين على اغلاق
محالهم التجاريه بالتسامن مع مرور المسيره
من البلده القديمه حيث يعتدي المشاركون
فيها على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين ويهتفون
الموت للعرب رافعين الاعلام الاسرائيليه
عام 2021 حمل تطورا مهما تحت تهديد
المقاومه الفلسطينيه منعت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو مرور
المسيره عبر باب العامود باتجاه حائط
البراق وساحه البراق وحولت المسار الى باب
الخليل باتجاه حائط وساحه البراق لتفادي
مرورها فيما يسمى الحي الاسلامي
موعد المسيره انذاك مع شهر رمضان وبعد
تكرار اقتحام المستوطنين للمسجد الاقصى
المبارك اطلقت المقاومه الفلسطينيه دفعه
من الصواريخ باتجاه القدس المحتله فاجبرت
اجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه على تفريق
المسيره لتندلع عمليه سيف القدس بعد
انتهاء عمليه سيف القدس نظمت المسيره ضمن
مسارها التقليدي في الخامس عشر من حزيران
يونيو واعتبر ذلك اول قرار مهم للحكومه
الجديده في اسرائيل برئاسه نفتالي بنات
ليمر المستوطنون من باب العامود باتجاه
ساحه البراق واحتفظت مسيره الاعلام
بالمسار عينه العام الماضي
قدر عدد المشاركين فيها بنحو 70 الفا
وحشدت لها قوات الاحتلال نحو ثلاثه الاف
عنصر لتامينها واستدعت ثلاث كتائب تابعه
لحرس الحدود من صفوف الاحتياط عام 2022
والساعه الجيش الاسرائيلي من دائره نشر
منظومه القبه الحديديه حول القدس وفي
مناطق عده في وسط وجنوب اسرائيل تحسبا
لاطلاق المقاومه الفلسطينيه صواريخا في
توقيت تنظيم المسيره
[موسيقى]
قالت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه انها تحمل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه الكامله
والمباشره عما تسمى مسيره الاعلام
الاستفزازيه ونتائجها وتداعياتها ليس فقط
في القدس وانما على ساحه الصراع وفق
تعبيرها من جانبها حذرت الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه من ان المسيره ستؤدي الى توتر
والى تفجير الاوضاع
من جهه دعا القيادي في حركه حماس مشير
المصري اهالي القدس والضفه الغربيه
والداخل الى التصدي للمسيره والاشتباك مع
قوات الاحتلال وقال المصري ان المقاومه
رهن الاشاره للدفاع عن المسجد الاقصى
والقدس وافشالي مخططات تهويده
نحن على ثقه كامله بمقاومتنا الفلسطينيه
التي تعد العده لتحرير بيت المقدس من
براثن المغتصبين انها دوما
رهن الاستعداد للحفاظ على اولى القبلتين
وثاني المسجدين وثالث الحرمين الشريفين
وافشاري كل مخططات الاحتلال
من مدينه اوتاوا في كندا ينضم الينا
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك
دكتور مصطفى ما الذي يمكن ان ينجم عن هذه
المسيره غدا
هذه المسيره تمثل خطوه اخرى من التصعيد
الكافي الذي تنظم الحكومه الفاسيه
الاسرائيليه لا يتوقف عن عمليات الاستفزاز
ليس فقط المسيره اليوم التي يهددون بها
والتهديدات كثيره بانه سيفتحم المسجد
الاخر والقرار الذي مره في قراءه
التمهيديه الان في الكنيست بتحريم رفع
العلم الفلسطيني كلها استفزازات تعبر عن
امرين ان هذه الحكومه الفاشيه العنصريه لا
تفهم ولا لغه القوه والمقاومه التي ستتصدى
لمؤامراتها ولكن ايضا
لا تعرف ماذا تفعل لكي توقف مقاومه الشعب
الفلسطيني ولجوهم الى منع رفع العلق مثلا
لا يعبر الا عن ثقافه مطلقه فليس الشعب
الفلسطيني بحاجه لابنه كي يرفع علم الذي
قدم مئات الشهداء
في ظل هذه الاجواء المتوتره بشده دكتور
مصطفى
والتحذيرات الفلسطينيه من انفلات الامور
بسبب الاستفزازات الاسرائيليه الى اين
يمكن ان تذهب الامور
نحن قلنا اكثر من مره ان اسرائيل تدفع
الامور وتصعيد كامل والنتيجه ستكون
انتفاضه شامله في كل ارجاء فلسطين ليس فقط
في القدس وليس فقط في الضفه الغربيه وليس
فقط في غزه بل حتى في الداخل هذه الحكومه
الفاشيه العنصريه تدفع الشعب الفلسطيني
باخره لمواجهتها ولن يتردد في فعل ذلك
الذي يجري فعليا هي انتفاضه تتصاعد
تدريجيا بشكل مختلف عن السابق لان الشعب
الفلسطيني ادرك ويدرك انه لها سوى
المقاومه وليس امامه لكي يحافظ على حياه
ابنائه وبناته ومستقبله هو ان يقاوم بكل
ما يستطيع من قوه وبكل الوسائل الدكتور
مصطفى ما احتمالات ان يتكرر سيناريو ما
حدث في عام 2021 عندما انطلقت صواريخ
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ردا على هذه المسيره
وفتحت الامور على مواجهه كبيره
كل شيء ممكن ولكن الامر يعتمد بشكل محدد
على ما يحدث تحديدا يوم غد وكيف سيكون
السلوك الاسرائيلي اذا تصاعدت الاعتداءات
وارتكبت
[تصفيق]
وليس فقط من الكتاب طيب دكتور مصطفى
السلطات الاسرائيليه اعلنت كذلك في موازاه
الدعوات الى قيام هذه التظاهره ودعمها من
قبل الحكومه وقول نتنياهو انها ستثير
بالمسار بمسارها المحدد كان هناك ايضا
اعلان عن منع بعض النشاطاء اليهود من
الدخول الى القدس هل من دلاله لذلك
باعتقادك
لاعب
ولكن هناك مسمى هو واضح طيران موجودان في
اسرائيل تيار مجنون فاشل عنف يريد ان يجور
المنطقه الى مواجهه تصدر هذا التيار طبعا
ولكنه يخشى من نتائج هذه الافعال خاصه
اننا نرى تراجعا
في سوره
بما في ذلك قرارات ضد الامر الاسرائيلي
سيجد اليوم في مناطق عبيده في الدنيا
بالتالي انا اعتقد ان هذا الذي نراك على
الارض
للاسف الشديد المنظومه الصهيونيه بكاملها
عنصريه وترتكب هذه الجهه شكرا لك الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ضيفا من مدينه اوتا
والكنديه
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الباكستانيه السابق
عمران خان ان الشرطه طوقت منزله في محاوله
لاعتقاله مره اخرى كما طالب خان في خطاب
نشره على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لاجراء
تحقيق قضائيا مستقل في اعمال الشغب التي
اعقبت اعتقاله المؤقت مطلع شهر الحالي على
ذمه قضايا فساد وكانت محكمه اسلام مبادئ
العليا قد مددت قرارها بمنع اعتقال رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان في القضايا
المرفوعه ضده الى الحاد والثلاثين من
الشهر الجاري لكن هيئه المحاسبه استدعته
وزوجته للوصول امامها الخميس للرد على
المزاعم الوارده في واحده من تلك القضايا
لما العجله انها الاوامر
متاعب الرئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق
تتناسل لا يسال عمران خان عن دواعي
الاصرار على معاوده اعتقاله لكنه يقول انه
يخشى اليوم من ان باكستان في طريقها الى
الدمار اذا لم يتم تغليف الحكمه
تتحدث السلطات الباكستانيه عن اعمال شغب
مميته تخللتها مهاجمه منشات امنيه ومقر
حكوميه وتنسبها الى انصار رئيس الوزراء
السابق
تبرئ عمران خان نفسه من الفاعلين وطالب
بتحقيق النزيه كما نفع عن نفسه الاتهامات
بالكسب غير المشروع
ومع ذلك استدعته هيئه المحاسبه وزوجته
للمثول امامها الخميس في القضيه المعروفه
بارض جامعه القادر هي القضيه التي كان خان
قد اعتقل بسببها قبل عشره ايام لفتره
وجيزه الحقيقه ان عمران خان الذي اطيح به
في تصويت على الثقه بالبرلمان في ابريل
العام الماضي يواجه قضايا فساد عده انصاره
يرون في المساله برمتها فارا سياسيا من
الرجل الذي يقود حمله شعبيه ضد الحكومه
الحاليه والجيش واسع النفوذ اذ يتهمهما
بالتواطئ لاقالته من منصبه والتورط في
فساد هائل بل ويتوعد هؤلاء جميعا
بالمحاسبه اذا عاد الى الحكم تلك هي
المشكله للبلد شواغل اكبر يقول مراقبون
محايدون فلم المخاطره بتعميق حاله عدم
الاستقرار السياسي في باكستان التي تعاني
بالفعل اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه على الاطلاق
انها من الاحتمالات التي تقلق
الباكستانيين وجيرانهم وحلفائهم اما
بالنسبه لنجم رياضه السابق فهذه مباراه
نوع اخر فرضت عليه ولا يبدو انها من النوع
الذي ينتهي بالاعتزال
معنا من شوكه براتشا الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي مرحبا بك سيد شوكت لماذا هذا
الانتشار الكثيف الامني الكثيف حول منزل
عمران خان
في الحقيقه هذه عمليه بدات
مسار مسارا بدا منذ فتره طويله في العام
الماضي
عمران خان واجه التصويت بطرخ الثقه ومذاك
كان يكافح وكان يواجه هذه
الحملات ويخوض الحملات السياسيه في وجه
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني الجديد شهباز
شريف ولكن في الوقت نفسه يمكننا ان نتحدث
عن الاحداث التي اندلعت بعد التاسع من
ايار مايو عندما تم اعتقال عمران خان في
اسلام اباد
وكان هناك تصريحات انتشرت
ان
المناصرين لعمران خان قاموا بعمليات تخريب
طالت المنشات العسكريه كانت هذه نقطه تحول
في مسار عمران خان في لاهور وفي تشاور هذه
الهجمات ادت الى انتشار مشاعر الغضب
وسلسله من الاحداث في باكستان
وشهدت باكستان سلسله من الاجتماعات على
المستوى الحكومي بالاضافه الى لجنه الامن
القومي
واجتماع قياده الجيش التي اتخذت قرارات
حاسمه في ظل مشاعر الغضب هذا التي تتحدث
عنها وفي ظل التحذيرات والمخاوف من
امكانيه انفلات الاوضاع مجددا لماذا تقوم
السلطات بهذه الخطوه بنشر هذه الاعداد من
العناصر العسكريه والام نيه في محيط منزل
خان بما يدفعه الى اتهامها بانها تريد ان
تلقي القبض عليه من جديد
عمران
هذا ما يقوله عمران خان هو صرح وقال ان
السلطات تسعى الى اعتقاله ولكن السلطات من
ناحيه اخرى في لاهور حيث يتواجد هو الان
تتحدث عن عدد من الارهابيين المطلوبين
للعداله والذين يلجاون الى منزل عمران خان
وارسلت هذه القوات الامنيه وقوات الشرطه
التي اشرت اليها
لاعتقال هؤلاء وامهل عمران خان لتسليم
هؤلاء
وتودوا السلطات ان تدخل الى منزل عمران
خان قال انه سوف يسلم الارهابيين اذا ما
وجدوا اذا ما وجدوا ولكن ان الحكومه
هي تتهموا عمران
بوائي الارهابيين هذا ليس الامر الحقيقي
وليست المعضله الحقيقيه المعضله الحقيقيه
في باكستان نحن نواجهها منذ فتره طويله
هناك
مساله مرتبطه
بالمحاسبه وهيئه المحاسبه في حقيقه الامر
ارسلت مذكره
لعمران خان
للمحاسبه بشان القضيه التي
تمت اشاره اليها في الماضي وبالتالي
بالنسبه الى عدد كبير من الناس في
باكستان عمران خان اثار هذه الزوبعه
الليله بانه بالامكان ان يتعرض
للتوقيف لكي يحيد بانتباه الناس عن
المساله الاساسيه
المرتبطه بهيئه المحاسبه الا وهي النقطه
الاساسيه
وتم التوصيل الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا التي تتاهب لجوله انتخابيه
الثانيه لحسم الرئاسه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان مرشح تحالف الجمهور قال في
كلمه متلفزه انه سيزور خلال الايام
المقبله المواطنين المنكوبين بكارثه
الزلزال منتقدا البلديات والمنظمات
المدنيه التابعه لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
لقطعها المساعدات عن المتضررين وطردهم من
الفنادق التي تاويهم بناء على نتائج
الانتخابات في المحافظات التي ينتمون
اليها
شاهدنا كيف يتهجموا انصار ومؤسسات وتحالف
الشعب على من لم يقدم الدعم لهم بمن فيهم
متضررون الزلزال بطريقه الله هي انسانيه
ولا سياسيه لقد قامت البلديات والمنظمات
المدنيه التابعه لحزب الشعبي الجمهوري
بعمل شنيع بما فيها قطع المساعدات عن
مناطق الزلزال وحتى طردوا لاجئيه زلزال
لان المحافظات المنكوبه لم تصوت لحزبهم في
الانتخابات ندرك انهم مدعومون من المنظمات
الارهابيه الانفصاليه ونعرف انهم يستخدمون
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بطرق غير لائقه
في المقابله اتهم مرشح تحالف الشعب في
تركيا كمالك الاشدار اوغلو الرئيس التركي
بالتغافل عن دخولي عشره ملايين لاج غير
شرعي لتركيا طمعا في الحصول على اصواتهم
موجها النداءه للشعب التركي للتخلص مما
وصفه مما وصفهم بالعاجزين عن حمايه حدود
تركيا وشرفها
اوجه نداء للجميع وطننا غالي وعزيز ولن
نتركه لطعمه ادخلت عشره ملايين لاجئ غير
شرعي لتركيا طمعا في اصواتهم لقد قال
النظام الحاكم ان الحدود شرفه لكنه عجز عن
حمايه الحدود وحمايه شرافه ايضا بينما هو
ينظر بعجز ودون قوه او حيده امام تسرب
اللاجئين الى اورردنا ودمائنا لن نترك
الوطن لزعيم يدعي زورا انه زعيم على مستوى
العالم بينما يستجدي روسيا واقفا على
ابوابها
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه واثق من
ان قاده الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
سيتوصلان لاتفاق بشان الميزانيه وان
الولايات المتحده لن تتخلف عن سداد
التزاماتها الماليه اضاف بايدن ان قاده
الكونجرس يدركون العواقب الكارثيه للتخلف
عن سداد تلك الالتزامات
انا واثق من اننا سنتوصل الى اتفاق على
الميزانيه ولن تتخلف امريكا عن سداد
ديونها كل قيادي في الغرفه يعي عواقب
التخلف عن سداد التزاماتنا الماليه وان
ذلك سيكون كارثيا على الاقتصاد والشعب
الامريكي
وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن قد اجتمع
مع رئيس مجلس النواب كاظم واعضاء الكونجرس
لتقريب وجهات النظر والتوصل الى اتفاق
يجنب البلاد كارثه اقتصاديه حقيقيه
وسط خلافات عميقه بين الجمهورين
والديمقراطيين بشان سقف الديون اجتمع
الرئيس بايدن مع رئيس مجلس النواب في
محاوله جديده لتقريب وجهات النظر والعثور
على اتفاق يجنب البلاد كارثه اقتصاديه
حقيقيه ياتي الاجتماع في ظل مزيد من
التحذيرات الرسميه كتلك التي وردت من مكتب
الميزانيه بالكونجرس والذي ذكر الطرفين
بضروره الاتفاق لان البلاد ربما تتخلف عن
دفع مستحقات ديونها بحلول منتصف الشهر
المقبل والتي بلغت حتى الان واحدا وثلاثين
تريليون دولار فاصل اربعه اذا لم يتم حل
الازمه وبسرعه عقب مغادرته البيت الابيض
اوضح رئيس مجلس النواب كيف ان الخلافات
مستمره وانه تم الاتفاق فقط على الاستمرار
في التفاوض
من الممكن التوصل للاتفاق مع نهايه
الاسبوع الحالي الامر ليس صعبه في حاله
سابقه في عهد رؤساء السابقين تمكن
السياسيون من تجاوز خلافاتهم وتم رفع سقف
الدين الامريكي لكن التشاؤم يخيم هذه
المره على معظم المراقبين بواشنطن بسبب
تشدد الاعضاء الجمهوريين الجدد الداعمين
لمكارتي بمجلس الشيوخ ونواب والذين دخلوا
الكونغرس في الانتخابات النصفيه الاخيره
بحسابات مختلفه
هؤلاء الجمهوريون متشددون ولديهم ولاء
لدونالد ترامب وهم يرون ان اي ضرر يمس
الاقتصاد وبايدن يضع ترامب في موقع افضل
اعتقد انهم غير مكترثين بازمه سقف الدين
من اجل اتفاق جديد حول سقف الدين الامريكي
يطالب الجمهوريون الرئيس بيضا الديمقراطي
بخفض برامج الانفاق الحكومي الذي كان وعد
بها الناخبين بنسبه لا عن عشرين بالمئه
والا فانهم مستعدون كما يقولون للمضي قدما
في مواقفهم ولو تطلب الامر ركودا اقتصاديا
حتى الان يرفض الرئيس بايدن والديمقراطيون
الردوخ لمطالب الجمهوريين ويعتبرون شروطهم
غير مقبوله لذلك انطلقت لعبه المفاوضات
كما يصفها المراقبون والتي يجب ان تسرع
حسب قولهم لان البلاد لن تكون قادره على
دفع المستحقات الشهر المقبل وستكون
النتائج كارثيه حسبا مختلف التنبؤات لم
تتوقف وزيره الخزانه الامريكيه عن تكرار
التحذيرات الرسميه للسياسيين قبل واثناء
وبعد مفاضت البيت الابيض لكن دون جدوى دون
ان تلقى اجابات حقيقيه هو مريحه من
الجمهوريين المتشددين في مواقفهم حتى الان
ما زالت الوزيره غير قادره حتى الان على
طمانه الامريكيين الجزيره واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اعلان من الرئيس التركي ثم تاكيد من موسكو
بالموافقه على تمديد العمل باتفاق تصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه لشهرين اضافيين فما هي
مسارات السفن التي تنقل الحبوب من موانئ
اوكرانيا للعالم تنطلق السفن من ثلاثه
موانئ اوكرانيه على البحر الاسود وهي
موانئ يوجيني واوديسا وتشورنو ويتم تفتيش
السفن قبل انطلاقها من اوكرانيا من قبل
ممثلين اوكرانيين واتراك وامميين تسلك
السفن ممرات امنه عبر البحر الاسود وتتم
متابعتها لضمان عدم تعرضها لاي هجوم ويعمل
مركز المراقبه في اسطنبول على مراقبه
السفن بالتنسيق مع دول المعنيه والامم
المتحده عند وصول السفن لمضيق البوسفور
التركي يتم توزيعها على الموانئ التركيه
وتخضع لجوله تفتيش جديده لتتحرك بعدها الى
وجهاتها الاخيره
بعد عوده السفن فارغه يتم تفتيشها في
الموانئ التركيه قبل ان تسلك الممرات
الامنه عائده الى اوكرانيا في التاسع
والعشرين من اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي
علقت روسيا مشاركتها بعد هجوم تعرض له
اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي ليستانف العمل
بالاتفاقيه بعد اعلان موسكو انا حصلت على
ضمانات مكتوبه من كييف بعدم استخدام
الممرات الامنه لاغراض عسكريه
الاتفاق على تمديد اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه جاء بعد تهديد موسكو بالانسحاب
منه اعتبارا من يوم غد بسبب عقبات امام
الصادراتها من الحبوب والاسمده
وشملت قائمه مطالب روسيا اعاده تشغيل خط
انابيب ينقل الامونيا الى ميناء اوكراني
على البحر الاسود
ورغم ان هذه الصادرات الروسيه لا تخضع
لعقوبات غربيه فرضت بعد الحرب في فبراير
شباط 2022 فان موسكو تقول ان القيود
المفروضه على المدفوعات والخدمات
اللوجستيه والتامين شكلت عائقا امام
الشحنات وتتهم روسيا مسؤولين اوكرانيين في
مركز التنسيق المشترك الذي يشرف على تنفيذ
الاتفاق في اسطنبول تتهمهم برفض بحث اعاده
تشغيل خط انابيب الامونيا نشير الى ان
اتفاقيه حبوب البحر الاسود تتضمن تامين
صادرات الحبوب العالقه في الموانئ
الاوكرانيه على البحر الاسود لمعالجه نقص
الغذاء العالمي الذي ينذر بكارثه انسانيه
وقد سمح الاتفاق بتصدير اكثر من 30 مليون
طن من الحبوب من اوكرانيا منذ بدء تطبيقه
في الاول من اب اغسطس الماضي وهما يكفي
لاطعام 150 مليون شخص لمده عام واحد لحسب
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيانيش للمزيد ينضم الينا من عمان عامر
الشوبكي الخبير في الشؤون الاقتصاديه سيد
عامر يعني كان هذا الاتفاق يترنح ولكن عاد
وسلك مساره الى التطبيق ما دلالات ذلك
والمشاهدين بالفعل كان يترنح واسواق القمح
العالميه ايضا كانت تتجهز لقفزه بعد ان
ارتفعت ايضا يوم الجمعه الماضي في اعلى
سعر منذ شهر الدلالات الان تقول بان
الامور تتجه الى التهدئه والاسعار ايضا
ستهدا وبالتالي العالم الان في فرصه وفي
فرصه عظيمه بعد ان رجعت اتفاقيه الحبوب
واتفاقيه البحر الاسود هذا الامر ريح
كثيرا من الدول وخاصه الدول العربيه نعم
طيب الان
انطونيو يقول ان المحادثات بشان القضايا
العالقه ستستمر رغم تطبيق هذا الاتفاق ان
لم يحدث اتفاق بشان هذا القضايا ما
الخطوره على استمراره
الصوره قادمه جدا لو بالفعل تم ايقاف
الاتفاق باعتبارا من غدا الخميس كان من
المفروض ان تبدا روسيا
بعدم المسؤوليه عن السفن التي تحمل القمح
وتتجه من اوكرانيا الى البحر الاسود ثم
الى يعني بحار العالم الى البحر المتوسط
هذا الامر كان سيرفع اسعار القمح بشكل
كبير 7% تستحوذ اوكرانيا على صادرات القمح
العالميه حصتها من سله القمح العالميه
وكذلك دول كثيره مستورده للقمح كانت
ستتاثر من الاسعار
بدايه عدا عن طبعا الضرر الثاني من انقطاع
مصدر القمح في اوكرانيا مثلا التي تقريبا
تزود 25% من سله الغذاء او القمح العربيه
نعم طيب نريد ان نفهم اكثر سيد عامر موضوع
التحفظات الروسيه لسيما يتعلق بالاشكاليه
حول خط انابيب الامونيا ما هو ما هي هذه
الاشكاليه وكيف السبيل الى حلها
نعم اعتقد بان روسيا ايضا تعترض على بعض
العقوبات على رجال اعمال الروس وعلى البنك
الحكومي الزراعي الروسي وهذا ربما سيكون
مفتاح
لايقاف هذا الاتفاق حتى بعد شهرين او في
اشهر قادمه وكذلك انبوبه الايمونيا وعده
يعني عناصر ايضا تصدر من الموانئ
الاوكرانيه قد لا تتحمل روسيا مسؤوليتها
في الفتره القادمه هي اوراق ضغط بيد روسيا
بعد ان فقدت الكثير من اوراق الضغط خاصه
سلاح الطاقه الذي كانت توجهه الى اوروبا
والان اوروبا في مامن وبعيده عن الطاقه
الروسيه نعم اشكرك عامر الشوبك الخبير في
الشؤون الاقتصاديه ضيفنا من عمان شكرا
جزيلا لك
نعود الان الى موضوع الانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه قبيل الجوله الثانيه من هذه
الانتخابات تنضم الينا من اسطنبول اسراء
اوزتورك الكاتبه الصحفيه والمحلله
السياسيه مرحبا بك سيده اسراء
ما ابرز الملفات والقضايا التي يركز عليها
كل طرف في حمله في هذه المرحله
قبيل الذهاب نحو جوله الاعاده
في البدايه نحن نتوقع هذه الجوله الثانيه
توقعنا هذه الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
عدد كبير من الناس كان قد توقع ذلك ولذلك
لم نتفاجا لذلك
هذه الجوله بدات الحملات الانتخابيه
بشانها من قبل الطرفين كلاهما جاهز من جهه
لدينا مرشح اقترب من حاجز الخمسين بالمئه
في الجوله الاولى الا وهو رجب طيب اردوغان
ومن ناحيه اخرى كمال اجلو حقق القمر ويسعى
الى تحصينها اذا لم يتغير الكثير باستثناء
اصوات المرشحه الثالثه الا وهو السيد سنان
غاند هذه الاصوات يمكن ان المؤثره على
مصير الانتخابات في جولتها الثانيه
ووفقا لاستطلاعات الراي ووفقا لما نراه في
تركيا من الواضح ان رجب طيب اردوغان لديه
الافضليه بالنسبه الى الجوله الثانيه ويجب
ان نتذكر في الوقت نفسه ان السيد كمال قد
جدار اوغلو يحاول اذكاء المشاعر القوميه
في البلاد لانه يحاول كما سبق واشرنا ان
يحصل على اصوات التي صبت لصالح اوغان ولكن
ليس لديه الكثير من الوقت في هذه الايام
العشر الاخيره يحاول ان يحث ان خبيين ولكن
من ناحيه اخرى نرى ان السيده روان مرتاح
اكثر لنتيجه المرتقبه سنان اوغان لديه
يعني حصل على هذه الخمسه في المئه تقريبا
من الاصوات الى اين يمكن ان يوجهها وما هي
شروطه لكلا الطرفين وهو يقول انه منفتح
على المحادثات مع الطرفين
مشكله في التقطع الصوت بنسبه الى سنان
اوغان اعتقد ان هذا هو السؤال سوف اتحدث
عن هذا الموضوع اذا
حصلت على الكثير من المعلومات في خلال
مقابله مع سنان اوغان في السابق هناك الان
يحاول ان لا يكشف كل اوراقه للعلن هو
السياسي وهو يعرف ان لديه موقع مميز يعطيه
افضليه في الوقت نفسه
[موسيقى]
بحاجه الى اصواته الى اصوات
اذا بنسبه الى سنان اوغان لديه رساله او
لديه مواضيع حساسه بالنسبه الى موضوع حزب
العمال
نحن نتحدثوا عن مساله حساسه بالنسبه الى
سنان اوغان وايضا التحالف القومي من ناحيه
اخرى هذا الارتباط ايضا بحزب الله هو
مساله حساسه بالنسبه اليه وبالتالي
بالنسبه الى الجوله الثانيه يحاول ان
يحتفظ بهذه الاوراق لكي
يحدد المسار لديه هذا الموقع الذي يمكن ان
يستفيد منه ويقول اذا ما وافق الائتلاف
معي على هذه الشروط يمكنني ان ادعم هذا
الاعتراف والا اعطي الحريه للنقل الصحفيه
والمحلله السياسيه ضيفتنا من اسطنبول شكرا
جزيلا لك سنكتفي بهذا القدر لضيق الوقت
[موسيقى]
المشهد من ايطاليا هذه المره تحديدا منطقه
ايميليا رومانيا شماليه البلاد ثمانيه قتل
على الاقل واجلاء الالاف من منازلهم
واعلانو فورمولا 1 الغاء سباق الجائزه
الكبرى ما الذي حدث امطار غزيره واربعه
عشر نهرا صادت عن ضفافها وانهيارات ارضيه
وتدفق المياه عبر المدن وغرق الافدين من
الاراضي الزراعيه كانت مناطق واسعه في
شمال ايطاليا قد تعرضت لجفاف الشتاء
الماضي يضاف الى شح قياسي للامطار الصيف
الماضي اتى على المحاصيل الزراعيه لكن هذا
الربيع كان اكثر رطوبه وبروده من المعدلات
الطبيعيه من فترات الجفاف الطويله الى
الفيضانات الشديده ازدادت شده الكوارث
المتعلقه بالمياه عبر العالم على مدى
العقدين الماضيين مع ارتفاع درجات الحراره
العالميه الى مستويات قياسيه
فارس تعيدنا للتذكير بازمه المناخ
وتداعياتها وضروره التصدي لها
دمتم بالف خير شكرا لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]